So, now that we have seen multiple
aspects of how caches work,
let's summarize them for
a more realistic cache.
Let's say we have a 4kB,
4-way set associate cache with a 64-byte
line size with a write-back and
write-allocate write policies.
The processor, let's say, creates
64-bit addresses to access the cache.
When accessing this cache,
the 64-bit address will
be divided into offset bits,
index bits and tag bits.
First for
offset bits it's a 64-byte line, so
we need 6 bits, bits 0 through 5,
there are 6 of them.
Are going to tell us where
in the cache block we are.
Next we need to determine how
many sets this cache has.
It's a four kilobyte cache,
that's two to the 12th bytes.
The number of blocks
is that divided by 64.
Which is two to the sixth.
So we have two to the sixth
blocks in the cache.
It's a four-way set associative
cache which means that
every set has four blocks in it.
So we divide the number of blocks with
the number of blocks in a set and
we get two to the fourth, or 16 sets.
Now we know that we need four bits
to tell us which set we are in, so
bits six, seven, eight, and nine,
four of them are the index.
The bits that remain, bits 10
through 63, 54 of them are the tag.
Now, in our cache,
we will have for each block.
A valid bit.
It's a write-back cache, so
you also have a dirty bit.
Then there will be a tag, 54 bits.
It's a 4-way set-associative cache, so
we need to pick a replacement policy.
Let's say the replacement policy is LRU.
For a 4-way set-associative cache,
each block needs to have
a two bit LRU counter.
Here we have one, one, 54, two, and then
we have 64 bytes' worth of actual data.
As you can see we have 58
bytes in addition to the data.
So there is some overhead.
The cache size is usually expressed in
terms of how much data it contains.
But the actual size of the cache
array is larger because it needs to
contain all of these extra bits for
each line of data.